heart we are told heart is uh genetics
it comes from your mom and dad and you
know every time I go to the doctor to
ask me a question did your mom have a
heart attack no how about your dad my
dad has 13 heart attacks really yes how
old was his first one 44 how many has he
had 13 has he had an open heart surgery
yes does he have stents yes three of
them how many angiograms he's had six
angiograms six angioplastics you got to
be careful because you may have it right
so what they don't know is my dad smokes
cigarettes two packs a day for 30 years
and he drank a full glass of alcohol
every single day for 30 years is what he
did I don't smoke I don't drink so what
is the cause of heart disease and why
heart attacks take place
so you know we're gonna have to go back
just remember just remember sixth grade
sixth grade simplified for us all right
I'm trying I'm trying my best Patrick
um first of all uh here's you know we
have to base every answer I give I want
it to be based on fact right
observations and fat so fact number one
um in 1920 in this country there was
almost no heart disease everybody
acknowledges that in fact there's an
interesting story that a guy invented
the EKG at Harvard Medical School
offered it to the Harvard faculty and
they said there's no use for this
there's no heart disease in this country
and whenever traditional indigenous
people are studied they have no evidence
of heart disease they have no evidence
of dying of heart attacks now I don't
know about your concept of genetics but
we're talking two or three generations
ago we went from almost nobody having
heart attacks and by the way if you look
at a cookbook from 1920 and you say what
were the healthiest foods that people
should eat it was very clear butter lard
and eggs and cream
nobody had heart attacks the fact that
now in 1940 just one generation later it
became the number one killer of
Americans there is no possible way that
has anything to do with genetics see now
I got smarter Tom I'm telling you what a
difference it made in the first 45
minutes and now I'm telling you that was
ridiculous so 1920 no heart disease just
two or three generations ago in a 1920
cookbook they're talking about butter
lard and eggs in 1940 a generation later
they're calling that the number one
killer so who wrote the 1940 cookbooks
and who made us think that these things
kill us with heart attacks and then when
do we start having heart attacks we
started having heart attacks with the
two major things happened one the major
change in the American diet again away
from uh healthy fats and towards
margarine Crisco and other processed
foods uh three things two and the second
thing was the widespread use of
chemicals in agriculture and food and
DDT and all the rest of it and three was
the increasing electrification of the
Earth which we now know interferes with
your ability to generate uh oxygen and
to use oxygen so as soon as those thing
three things happen you see this
epidemic this epidemic of heart disease
now here here's another thing Patrick
you know if you ask a hundred doctors
100 lay people 100 people off the street
why do people have heart attacks right
they say the exact same thing you have
these three major coronary arteries they
carry all the blood to your heart one of
them gets blocked with plaque or two of
them or three of them the blood can't
get through and then you have a heart
attack and die
right sure everybody knows that yep you
with me I'm with you this part I'm with
you sixth grade fully qualified got it
okay now let's dissect this out a little
bit uh I've seen probably a hundred
people come to my office
say 50 year old man
uh let me stop for a minute here let me
go back a little bit so would you agree
that if there's something blocking your
arteries it's probably in your blood
sure right second question do you think
the blood in your art in your coronary
arteries the heart arteries is the same
blood as you have in your spleen and
liver and foot and everywhere else I
would assume so yes I would too okay so
the blood leading to your spleen has
whatever it is that's causing the plaque
just like in the coronary arteries
so you must get plaque in your splenic
artery as well
right sure yes now how many people have
you heard of who've had spleen attacks
[Laughter]
I've never heard of spleen attacks so I
I have given lectures to maybe 50 to 100
000 people in my career one of the
questions if I'm talking about heart
please raise your hand if you've heard
of anybody or know of anybody who had a
spleen attack a liver attack a foot
attack or a kidney attack you know how
many people raise their hands none none
now next question how many of you know
somebody personally or in the news who
had a heart attack
plenty hundred percent sure how come
same arteries same blood same plaque how
come
next question guy comes to me I've seen
this probably off 50 times maybe a
hundred times because I wrote a book
about the heart I have a medicine yeah
people come to me 50 year old guy doc I
walked up a hill I felt a little
pressure in my chest I went to the
doctor he said oh you might have heart
disease we gotta check your arteries
does an angiogram says you have a 95
blockage usually they go like this and
if you block anymore you're going to die
of a heart attack right
I've heard that a hundred times let's
think about this for a minute we're told
that all the blood to your heart goes
through those three arteries right sure
that's why they unblock them
you not you but the guy came to me you
have a five percent blood flow through
your artery okay how did you walk up
that hill
next question you mean if you not you
but that guy you block from five percent
to three percent that's gonna kill you
I don't believe it
five percent is no blood flow three
percent five percent exactly the same
there is no evidence that that makes any
difference at all
next thing there was the biggest study
ever done on people who died of heart
attacks they did it with autopsies a guy
named Giorgio baroldi what year was this
what what year was it
2000 something so this is recent it's
not a 20s or 40. it's a recent note
if you want to read the entire book if
you're a glutton for scientific
punishment go to Heart attacknew.com at
the bottom there's a print version
beraldi uh prints the whole version does
autopsies 50 years on people who die of
heart attacks he says 41 of them have a
blocked arter
and of that blockage 50 come after the
heart attack not before
so if you do the math that means that 80
percent of the heart attacks have are
have no evidence of any blockage in the
in the artery leading to that part of
the heart none now the when I wrote the
book I pointed that out and said what is
the reason why these other 80 percent
die
and in fact if you look at the studies
of stents and bypasses right so these
are mechanisms or strategies to clear
out the arteries if it was just a
blockage it should work
every single one of them the conclusion
is there's no evidence that having a
stent makes you live longer or not have
a second heart attack
and then in October 2018 in the Lancet
for the first time they did a blinded
study of stents right so they took I
don't know how many I think 70 people
who had a single vessel blockage right
half of them they put a stent in the
other half they put a catheter in they
told them they put a stent in but didn't
and they assessed them eight weeks later
they had the exact same amount of chest
pain
so not in the headlines of the article
was stents proven useless
now it's therefore proven that stents
don't prevent further heart attacks they
don't make you live longer and they
don't help you have less chest pain
so it's very difficult to say so what is
the benefit
and I can't think of any and in the
article they said there must be
something else that is causing people to
have heart attacks
and essentially then the European Heart
Association redid their typology of
heart disease and said 60 to 80 percent
of people who have heart disease signs
and symptoms have no evidence of any
plaque buildup so essentially the whole
plaque thing at most it has to do with
20 and the fact of the matter is most of
the blood flow to our heart doesn't come
from this these arteries anyways but it
it is basically a watershed with
millions of little capillaries just like
a watershed instead of a river and when
you have disease in how you generate
energy then you have a heart attack
[Music]